hola
les aseguro que si yo pregunto en esta
mañana cuántos de ustedes recuerdan
haber jugado en la en el barrio en la
calle de la paz del barrio o colonia
donde ustedes nacieron muchos se
identificarían conmigo uno de los
recuerdos más lindos que yo tengo de mi
infancia es justo haber podido jugar en
el bar en la calle del barrio donde yo
nací
a pesar de estas libertades físicas con
las que tuve el privilegio de nacer
también nací y crecí con muchas
limitaciones mentales económicas
estas limitaciones me impedían
visualizar me un poco en el futuro
siempre supe que quería hacer algo
relacionado con el arte y con la cultura
pero estás imposibilidades me impedían
soñar
si esa gran ahí soy yo
el tema arte y cultura no debe ser
relacionado únicamente con nosotros los
gestores culturales o con los artistas
él
el tema de cultura está estrictamente
relacionado con nuestro adn es decir lo
llevamos en nuestra sangre
pero para que entremos un poquito en el
tema sobre cultura empecemos por definir
qué es cultura cultura según estos
diccionarios que ustedes tienen por
todos lados que ya no existen en escrito
casi pero si ustedes google lean cultura
es todo aquella tradición es todo
aquello que identifica a un pueblo a una
nación a una persona pero una de las
definiciones más impactantes para mí
sobre cultura está detallada en su forma
más simple lo esencial del hábitat y lo
esencial es aquellos sin lo cual no
podemos vivir
es así que la cultura ignorarla o
pasarla por alto siempre va a ser
catastrófico para nuestras vidas y para
nuestras sociedades
la cultura ha sido tan importante a
nivel mundial que los países más
desarrollados en el mundo lo son gracias
al desarrollo de sus temas culturales y
artísticos tanto es así que hace más de
10 años
la unesco nos habla de las industrias
culturales y creativas
qué son estas industrias en sí son
aquellas que se dedican a la producción
a la reproducción a la promoción a la
difusión y a la comercialización de
temas relacionados con cultura arte y
patrimonio nacional
en ese sentido en honduras
el tema que nos compete en el 2016
fuimos mencionado por cnn como uno de
los países destinos más importantes de
latinoamérica gracias al tema cultural
igual banco mundial nos mencionó
diciendo que en honduras la cultura les
robaba espacios a la violencia
escucharon bien el banco mundial dijo en
honduras la cultura les roba espacios a
la violencia
y así a través de la cultura hoy tenemos
a fuera de nosotros afuera de honduras
artistas de la talla de hunán ahora
buchanan exponiendo en toda
latinoamérica desde argentina y
terminando en taiwán en la industria
creativa de la moda tenemos a un yoyo
barrientos juega un avión y de castañeda
vistiendo a artistas internacionales en
esa misma línea en el área de modelaje
tenemos a una masa de crisanto que de
hecho nos acompaña aquí en esta mañana
poniendo su afro como un statement de
qué es la cultura nacional en la
industria cinematográfica un alejandro
irías con varios premios ganados a nivel
internacional y así podría estar toda la
mañana mencionando las artistas
nacionales que se han internacionalizado
de una forma muy importante poniendo
fuera de nuestro país
la cara de honduras muy en alto
en honduras particularmente únicamente 5
millones de lempiras anuales son
destinados para temas relacionados con
la art y cultura
de esos 58 kings verdad de esos 5
millones les voy a dar una cifra más
impactante todavía de esos 5 millones
únicamente el 15% está destinado para
cultura
a pesar de esa imposibilidad económica
estos artistas que les acabo de
mencionar hondureños
cuyo adn está lleno de nuestra cultura
ann intern ha internacionalizado el
nombre de honduras
entonces mi pregunta es cómo hacemos
para dejar de ser espectadores y tomar
un asiento en la silla de los que hacen
algo por nuestro país tengo el honor de
hace un año haber creado junto a mi
mejor amiga masai crisanto el sitio web
light las bahamas aid o live hasta que
yo la by más ay la vida de una crowd
criolla este sitio web está destinado a
empoderar la mujer hondureña a través
del arte y de la cultura
tenemos el honor de colaborar con
distintos artistas nacionales desde
músicos gente en la industria creativa
de la moda
artistas en plástica centros culturales
de nuestra ciudad y de nuestro país
escuelas y muchos otros proyectos en
comunidad que nos han hecho dejar de
solamente ver un problema y actuar a
favor del país
hoy
estoy aquí para hablarles que el arte y
la cultura tiene la oportunidad de
cambiar la cara de honduras cambiando
primeramente la nuestra consumir y
revolucionar a través del arte y de la
cultura es un acto de valentía pero
también es un acto de voluntad no
necesitamos dinero no necesitamos
conexiones con nadie lo único que
necesitamos es una viva pasión por
nuestro país una pasión que sea capaz de
dejarnos atrás los temores
atrás las imposibilidades atrás todo lo
que alguna vez fue una barrera mental
para que podamos comenzar a hacer algo
por nuestro país no todos somos artistas
pero todos consumimos artes
no todos somos gestores culturales pero
por las venas de todos nosotros corren
tradiciones corren adn cultural hoy mi
propuesta de future you para ustedes y
para nosotros es que seamos nuestros
propios héroes nacionales buenos días
[Aplausos]